this is a production of Cornell
University
that's it's an honor to have you
introduce me Lance I really I really do
appreciate that so uh I will I will have
a disclaimer at the start here this is
kind of a jumble of things I'm going to
share with you today uh as seems
appropriate for uh I don't know an exit
seminar
I'm not ready yet but uh almost exit
seminar and I'd just like to share with
you kind of a really uh 40 000 foot view
of some of the things that uh my
colleagues and I have worked on over
these four plus decades and let's let's
dig in
so uh one of the things that I want to
you know help you uh especially younger
scientists understand a little bit if
you're interested in the kind of career
that I've had uh I am a generalist plant
pathologist with uh with crop
responsibility so what is that like what
is a career like that like and I I will
jump to say fantastic it really is but
go in with your eyes open uh because it
it really requires you know time
management and finding that balance in
life and balance between your your
research and your extension but uh you
know I've it's been a privilege to learn
learn new things at least weekly if not
daily uh and uh you work with a lot of
farmers and and suppliers and whatnot do
who often set you straight on what you
don't know and actually that's that's a
wonderful opportunity
you get to diagnose problems I love
problem solving and and uh you're not
going to find Perfect Solutions but
you'll find the best at that moment
and the key thing I think is you realize
in this kind of a position you work in a
team environment it's got uh it's not an
individual thing
and you get the chance to work with the
industry Growers and also a chance to
Mentor students which uh as as Lance
mentioned are the two things I've Loved
most about my career
okay so just briefly the this team and
some team members have changed over the
years but these are some of the
colleagues that I've been in the furrow
with if if you will through most of my
career and I see Margaret is here one of
one of my extension colleagues
uh
and it's a lot of fun you had a chance
to visit a travel the state uh check out
some pretty cool little diners stay in
some interesting little towns and you
really have a chance to bond with your
colleagues so my my position it
surprises some people to know it's 70
extension and uh this is probably
something we're not going to see a lot
in the future but I've really enjoyed it
it's fit my personality and what I've
enjoyed doing
but I've also equally enjoyed my
research assignment and it's allowed us
to get into all kinds of things uh over
the years
So and I've had I I can't linger in a
lot of these slides but I just want you
to know that I've had the privilege at
Cornell having to work with some just
exceptional people here you'll probably
recognize a few of those names these are
my uh technical staff research extension
support Specialists over the years and
thank goodness Kevin Myers is still with
me
uh
and uh graduate students uh wow really
been privileged in this Arena as well a
number of these students have gone on
after their PHD to be members of Faculty
uh literally around the world and uh
also USDA ARS scientists like our fine
example in the second row
and uh many of them are are also adjunct
faculty uh uh in their respective
universities
and I've trained people that have gone
on to very enjoyable productive careers
in Industry as well uh and again some of
that International
uh I might just mention for a moment
some in the other category when you're
thinking in graduate school you're
getting your degree thinking about what
what do you want to do you know about
industry you know about Academia how
many people know some of these things
Lara Litchfield Timber is now the
director of a children's science museum
in the Hudson Valley and is just doing
great at it
um Neil Rowe Miller
he always had an interest in in Mission
work he was a Mennonite student and he
spent his whole career in
non-governmental organizations fighting
hunger in different places in Africa so
that was a launching pad from him
um and Dennis Shaw some of you may know
Dennis he operates a Consulting business
out of uh near Niagara Falls New York
and he works with University people all
over the country to help them analyze
their data and put it in shape for
publication so there's a lot of
different kind of careers one should
think about
and likewise I've had the privilege to
have a number of really good uh
postdoctorals uh research Associates and
uh visiting scientists
so what is field crops anyhow you
probably get a different uh definition
and different institutions different
states around the country but in uh in
New York State uh we're looking at field
corn which is a big acreage crop 1.2
million Acres of fuel card in the State
uh hay in pasture land is also well over
a million Acres both of these things
strongly in support of the dairy
industry in the state
um soybean is just uh just taken over uh
since I started my position there was
about 10 000 acres in the state we're
we're knocking on a half a million Acres
the way it's going right now so uh
soybeans has really come on strong uh
small grains uh have always been
important as a rotational crop on our
farms and it happens that a lot of my
own research has been in that Arena I've
also had the chance in uh the last
decade or so to work on grasses that are
used as feedstocks for uh bioethanol and
and bio products like bioplastics and
also had a chance to get involved in
some of the Industrial Hemp work that's
that's fairly recent here at Cornell
so my general approach uh to feel crop
pathology or health the flip side there
is to just identify and assess the
problems uh try to you know the ones
that are important enough to really dive
into you try to understand the limiting
factors in those path of systems how
they're influenced by the the host by
the uh environment the crop rotation Etc
identify limiting factors and then
Target your control at those limiting
factors and then obviously make sure you
can have something that cures a disease
great but it it lowers yield or it does
something else detrimental so it really
needs to be delivered in an op in an
integrated sense
so anybody that knows me knows that
probably my favorite research tool
weapon is a disease survey and uh almost
everybody that makes it through my
program is going to spend time in the
field and uh more than likely do a
disease survey and we've done this on
all the crops you've seen on that list
before and I feel that this is just some
examples there on Alfalfa
verticillium will really threaten the
whole Alfalfa industry across the United
States when I first came on the job and
that's that's the thing I did on day one
is just try to to map that see where it
was look for patterns of that problem
and the wonderful story is our plant
breeders like Don vions came up in a
four or five years with wonderful
resistance to that and we hardly hear
boo about Earth Wilt today but I like
this approach because you get a real
world assessment of what's going on on
farms when it's going on and also I know
some people think that the only
worthwhile research is uh hypothesis
testing I would say that discovery
research were is a hypothesis generating
so I I feel that's an equally important
part of science
so uh amongst uh you know might sound
like we kind of shotgun all over the
place and in a sense we do and a lot of
things we've worked on have been for
short periods of time a couple of years
let's say to solve a particular issue
but I've had one common thread in my
research from day one to the present
still working on and that is uh working
with uh fusarium grimmini arum the Latin
is fusarium of the grasses and I've been
very interested in uh uh fusarium
problems a stock rot and erot on corn
and fusion head blight on small grains
and other grasses
um so what I'm going to try to do today
and I know I have more slides than I can
probably reasonably get through but
we're going to race through a few things
here but if anybody wants to talk to me
on detail on anything I'm always glad to
do that and after I talk about some of
this main line of research I'd like to
give you a little vignettes of research
in other smaller topics along the way so
that's kind of my game plan here
so I've been fortunate to be part of a
of a national in fact International
Coalition of scientists what a wonderful
group to work with the USDA IRS uh has
been funding this initiative called the
U.S wheat barley scam initiative
um for over 20 years now and I've been
very involved in that organization this
particular
um
publication in 2012 was kind of a review
of everything we know about that disease
and how to control it at that time and
obviously we've learned a lot since
and I've really been privileged to uh
really work so closely with Mark Swirls
and his crew uh in small grains breeding
and uh you may not be aware of it but
since I had to leave my lab in plant
science building I am now co-sharing a
lab with uh with Mark sorrell's uh crew
so that's working out very nicely
so I won't get down into too many
details but we've pursued all all the
different ways to control uh these
epidemics in in small grains and that
includes working with Mark and other
breeders to constantly select for
resistance and this is not the sort of a
pathogen that you get high levels of
resistance you get partial resistance
but uh we made some real gains there
and also at the same time uh for many
many years I've been screening uh uh
fungicides applied at the time that the
uh the weeder barley flower uh again you
don't get the big bang you might get a
50 reduction in the disease and in the
toxin the really with the with this
disease yes it hurts yield but the real
problem is the toxin deoxynavalinol or
Don
and if a farmer is going to sell their
grain to a flower Mill
they will not accept with anything more
than two parts per million of that toxin
doesn't take much in our wet environment
to get two parts per million if you want
to sell that uh to make beer for a Malt
House it has to be less than one part
per million so it's really a challenge
in the humid part of the world
so uh and even when you throw everything
at it that you have the tools if the
weather is favorable enough it's going
to overcome it and you're going to get
higher levels of the mycotoxins
so just uh just briefly hear uh this is
kind of uh common experiments uh over
the over the United States over a number
of years but it shows the principle here
all those bars above zero with zero
being the amount of control of the the
levels of the disease itself in yellow
and of the toxin
um ingest a completely susceptible
variety with no comical on it so as you
go from left to right you show the
increase in control first with just a
moderately susceptible variety uh and
then you with the with the best
fungicide at that time and then just
with the modern moderately resistant
variety alone and then all the way
throwing everything at it on the on the
right hand side there so we're still
we're we haven't solved that problem but
we're we're making strides so one part
of the initiative that our group has
particularly made contributions to is
understanding what role that cultural
control uh would have and by cultural
control here I primarily mean
um control of residues particularly of
corn in the area which are the spore
producing factories and these spores are
airborne as well as Splash dispersed so
and uh you get two kinds of spores ask a
spores which are they are they are
airborne and can be dispersed at a
distance and in macro Canadia which are
kind of locally dispersed but we've seen
a lot of Trends and their people have
made kind of jump to conclusions that if
you're you know first year a wheat and
you don't follow corn you shouldn't have
any problem well in our survey where
that's just plain not true we we see the
disease and we see toxin in the grain
even with first year corn on our first
year wheat crop on on cloud round
yeah that's just calling so you might
think well we should have less problem
because it's cold here over the over the
winter right well actually it's like
taking your cultures and sticking them
in the freezer and throwing them out
again the the organism actually persists
longer in our environment than in the
South where there's all kinds of
microbes working on them
so uh I have to credit uh an association
with uh Elson Shields and entomology
who's one of the country's real Pioneers
in aerobiology and uh you know Elsa and
I had discussed this problem for a long
time and he actually designed these uh
remote piloted aircraft with little uh
compartments that over open up that that
catch spores on a petri dish or on a on
a slide plate and we work with Elson for
a number of years and we established
that ask a spores in our area and others
are absolutely commonplace in the in the
planetary boundary layer above crops in
our agriculture so you think about that
and you say well why would we think it
would only be in fields where we didn't
have stubble from an over the crop and
in fact that's that's the line we
pursued and furthermore we looked at
well these things are up in the sky when
are they getting to deposited on the
wheat heads or The Barley heads and it
could happen anytime a night or day and
certainly when there's a rainfall event
the the rainfall the water droplets wash
these spores out of the soil out of the
air but also natural gravitational
settling of these Columns of air and the
still Air at night we collect far more
at night especially in the wee hours of
the morning than we do in the middle of
the day and it all kind of makes sense
for survival of the fungus dead Point
its likelihood to encounter the moisture
it needs
so the next line of Entry we looked at
is okay how far what's the the dispersal
distance locally we know things can get
up like a plume of smoke and move long
distances in the air but what what about
in the field and neighboring fields and
what we did is is we used uh genotype
clonal isolates that we uh infected corn
with and got infected corn stalks and we
cut them up they had single eye splits
in them and we put them out in field
plots and then we collected uh and and
over the top of that was was wheat
planted over a field and we collected uh
the wheat heads and isolated fungi from
them at various distances and also
further away hundreds of yards away in
the field and what we found is that
generally uh you know if you compare
with what you pick up in the distant
background most of that interference
with spores from a source like
cornstarch blocks are going to occur
within about six meters so we decided
we're going to look at this
experimentally that's the kind of
distances we'd have to consider
and so this was one of the most fun
things I've ever did I come one of the
farmers I worked with called this uh
what do you have those rabbit cages out
my field for so what we did is we went
into we we picked a uh a field
um of of wheat in this in the fall of
the Year these are winter wheat and then
we went to the closest Field of Corn
stubble as you can see in this wheat
field in the foreground we went to that
field next to it used our wonderful uh
measuring unit the hula hoop and
collected all the uh all the corn stalks
within that hula hoop and then we
transported that hula hoops worth of
corn debris over into this new Wheat
Field and we had these we had different
treatments and whatnot and had them
spread out and then we we followed the
disease that developed in those rabbit
cages that had corn stalks that didn't
have any corn stalks Etc
and uh This was done with Cooperators we
had 21 different trials uh spread across
different states and
um it was really kind of fun work and
what we found is that in the vast
majority of these we look at again I'm
keying in on the mycotoxin not the
disease symptoms because that's really
what we want if you see the contrast
between the red and blue bars from each
of those locations it's the level of
mycotoxin and it Compares uh
the the red is is uh the wheat heads
with with corn stalks right below them
and the blue is without so you can see
that yes uh the local inoculum makes
some difference but the regional
neighborhood inoculum makes more
difference and so out of all those
combinations uh we only saw
significantly higher down in three of
the situation well in in eight of 41
situations
so you might say well that's that's
small plots that's not that's not
agricultural scale what's really going
on so I I took that argument and I said
okay the next thing we're going to do is
try to test this on a commercial
agricultural scale and this was also fun
I had some wonderful collaborators you
see there and what we did in each of
these cases is we went into we found in
each of our states we found a a large
corn field
and with the Harvest uh in that fall or
let the the residue stay on the soil but
then we went in with
really uh commercial scale uh equipment
to plow under moldboard plow
wide strips where the all of the uh all
of the Corn stubble or you know large
percentage of it is Incorporated in the
soil and then other strips that were let
unplowed so we had these replicated
strips across fields in these locations
and then we immediately planted in a in
a Crossways Direction uh we we planted
the whole field over with winter wheat
in the fall
and we followed the crops into the next
year and we harvested the wheat heads
from those plots and as you can see here
um every there's Dynamics to this thing
some some years some places there's not
conducive conditions for the disease and
toxin generation others there are so if
you can see of these different
situations we looked at here uh on
average about we saw about a 22 percent
increase in the level of the mycotoxin
where corn stalks were under the wheat
heads and so what that really tells us
is the majority inoculum is coming from
outside of that and in cases where we
had you might call more epidemic
conditions where the background levels
were a half apart per million then we
then that was tweaked down a little bit
the absolute level of toxin went up a
little bit but as a percent it went down
so uh and here's another uh example
here I think I think I didn't have that
slide up on time here but that's kind of
what I just said so
there's not a single answer for this
kind of thing but I think we feel very
good for at least within wheat growing
areas of the eastern central United
States where they're basically in a corn
soybean background a lot of corn in the
area releasing spores we think that less
than 30 percent of this inoculum is
coming uh really from uh from the local
source of inoculum as as compared to the
regional neighborhood Source in in the
atmosphere
so uh We've also done a lot of work over
the years on the population biology of
this fungus
um and a lot of this is tied to uh the
mycotoxin chemotypes
and uh the main mycotoxin is
deoxynavalinol and that's closely
related as it sounds to nyvolinol
and there are two acetylated forms the
15 acetylated and three acetylated uh
Don and
you know most commercial testing is
strictly for Don so for starters we
wanted to see what else was out there
isolates that are 1580on produced Don
plus 1580on and the same thing for 3801
genotypes will produce Don and 3adon
Naval and all the isolates produced only
Naval
so uh we did a lot of survey work uh
first in New York and then the east
coast and uh we what we found is that uh
through most of the Corn Belt and and
most of the Northeast even it's
predominantly a 15 Adon population
of this fungus but we did find we did
find some three Adon in the population
and there's sort of a
a client if you will uh going from south
to North the further north the more we
were seeing the 381 population
yeah
they all produce Don it's the genotype
of 3adon means it produces the UN Plus
3adon
so we also took a look at this with
collaborators across the to the Midwest
and even into Vermont and we saw that
there's if you look across the Corn Belt
there's also a cline from east to west
where it looks like going east you're
seeing more of the 380on types
um interesting there's a client that's
been discussed in Canada for many years
where a lot of Eastern Canada has a lot
of three Don and a lot of you know uh
sort of uh Upper Midwest up into
Manitoba and places West has had a lot
more Don than other places there's an
exception
Ontario the biggest corn producing
County are uh province in Canada has
almost exclusively 15 a Don so there's a
feeling that there's a substrate thing
going on here too
so following up on this
um
Paulo coonam from Brazil was in my lab
and he started looking at this intensely
in New York state on different kinds of
uh environments and uh what he he really
showed that even further with with huge
sample sizes of isolates and there's
something unique up in the Northeast
area where we started looking that has
very little commercial production of
small grains or corn
but it does have some and also working
with our friends in New England and
Vermont in particular we found the same
thing there
so as you can see it's almost equal
populations of 3 and 15 a don
so
um Paulo uh he he teased that apart an
even more interesting way I mentioned
about substrates and stuff and so we had
three locations one of them is kind of
our Aurora is kind of our Corn Belt like
place okay a lot of corn and soybeans
grown and wheat uh willsboro is a
Cornell Farm up there and there's very
much there are very little surrounding
crops right around there uh you're right
up against the Adirondacks there's wild
grasses there's different things down in
the uh kind of Allegheny Plateau we also
had a location in Belmont New York and
we collected purposely I got isolates
from corn debris that had overwintered
on the ground from collection uh with
sport collection from the air the
atmosphere in those places with sport
Collections and from disease wheat heads
and what we found very strongly is this
genotype frequency it varies a lot by
region General background but not by the
specific a thick substrate in a specific
place
that's fascinating
so a little follow-up on that Northeast
New York at the time we were doing this
work there's a new there's a new
mycotoxin discovered that we didn't even
know about at the time it's called nx2
another variant off the the Don pathway
and we said what the heck let's have it
we had it tested in Minnesota and nearly
half of our 3adon genotypes because of
the way that the PCR thing is set up it
there's a first step PCR would detect it
as being an umbrella 380on but that also
hides the nx2 genotypes further a
further PCR different set of primers is
used and we find out that we also have
this nx2 genotype in fact it's the
highest population of nx2 genotype found
anywhere in the world now go figure uh
uh you know maybe they haven't looked
enough in some other places but it is it
is quite interesting that we have that
variation in our own backyard so it
makes New York State just a wonderful
living laboratory to look at some of
these questions
so a few things uh summaries from
Michael fulcher's uh popular uh
dissertation
um
and he describes these well it's been
described before these three or two at
least ancestral populations the 15a Don
the 3A Don and now we layer onto that
the nx2 and they they overlap but yet
they they they have distinct signatures
that a population that uh that he looked
at in his thesis work and um
still roughly and I said the nice thing
about working on this in New York is
we're kind of where the east west and
north-south Clines sort of come together
here so it's uh it's kind of fascinating
and uh again we've kind of talked about
that one of the additional things that
so you start thinking of all the
possibilities what what's really
affecting population structure uh here
and why why is there that Division and
uh we looked at things like temperature
there's a lot of things I'm not going to
show you because I don't have time but
one of the things we thought is the
overall background so if you're in a sea
of corn with little fields of small
grain you got you got corn uh spores
coming out of corn all over the place
right so that's probably going to have a
major effect in the Midwest and even
Western Central New York but we get into
some more marginal uh agricultural areas
where there's not a lot of cultivated
grains
we wondered about well maybe it's the
grasses that are driving the population
structure they're not necessarily uh
just the cultivated cereals so uh
Michael did many interesting things but
one of the things he he did is to look
at what the populations look like at an
interface between weedy grasses or
natural grasses and cultivation and one
of the one of the Laboratories he used
with the Montezuma National Wildlife
Refuge at the North End of the lake
which is which is essentially a huge
grassland so he uh he studied he
collected isolates there and also in a
fairly small radius from commercial
farms around that so I'm going to just
share a tiny bit of that
um one of the things he found and he got
those isolates and he wanted to see if
they differed in virulence on different
hosts and what I what you can see in
this slide uh the second set of bars in
both graphs from from your left uh that
indicates wheat and that shows the
production of a residue of wheat to
produce ascus4s compared to all those
other grasses and most of the natural
occurring grasses are as good of source
of spores as as is the cultivated cereal
so that's that's quite interesting and I
have to throw in there that it doesn't
cause the usual visual symptoms on the
uh on on the on the small uh grit on the
grasses it's it's very often symptomless
but when they die it grows out and they
sporulate so that's another interesting
feature
um
and we we got a hint that if you look at
large enough populations over big enough
distance you you might see some Trend
shaping population and one thing we saw
you know not real strong but we saw some
evidence that the isolates coming for
grasses weren't quite as virulent on the
wheat as as what was coming from weed or
corn but again that's kind of a trend
not a conclusion
all right so in the rest of the time I
would like to talk about my lab group
through the years and some of the folks
in it and give just very brief vignettes
of some of the other research we've been
able to work on so this is my first crop
of students if if you will and I don't
know if you know some of those folks in
there uh some of you know me know Nancy
Keller uh Dave Cal I think a lot of you
around here know Dave when he was my
research support specialist there but
it's a great group for me to start with
and the first vignette I'll share is
that we had some concentrated effort on
corn anthracinal stock Rod which was
really coming on and causing uh crop
loss about the time I started my
position
and again I'm not going to read
everything uh to you here but
particularly the the work of Nancy
Keller and muyimbo con colango in
particular they were able to do some
really neat work on crop loss assessment
and whatnot and showed that injury
wounding by the European corn bore
created an infection court for the
fungus that really increased the amount
of disease and and the amount of crop
loss
um we worked with Vernon Grayson at the
time Margaret's predecessor and and one
of his students from Africa and were
able to identify major genes separate
genes uh for resistance to the leaf
blight phase and to the stock rot phase
those are still in use in the industry
today
um we also uh were able to
identify BT corn was just starting to
come on then the transgenic corn with
against uh earworm or well different
different insects but in this case corn
bore and it was working very well in
diminishing the damage that we were
seeing from uh from this fungal stock
rod
um in particular muimba did some really
nice work uh looking at when we wounded
a corn stock either with a an insect or
with an ice pick or some kind of
artificial wound and introduced an
oculum at different periods of time he
also found that there's a very rapid
wound healing phenomenon that goes on in
corn so in addition uh what's what's
kind of interesting there is a as an
insect that's not just wounding and and
stop wanting it's continually wanting
and I don't show it here but we also had
evidence that the fungus passes through
the gut of the insect and it can
actually be an a vector for the uh for
the pathogen
um anime skilder uh was a both a masters
and PhD student with me and she did some
just beautiful work on uh tan spot
disease of Wheat really a thorough study
of the seed infection process and also
of of the uh she does some beautiful
histological work on the seed to
seedling transmission of this fungus and
um anyhow it's it's a very elegant work
if anybody's interested can talk to you
further
moving into the 90s and uh here we first
meet our friend uh Lance
and uh and some other new folks you see
Dennis Shaw there
um a number of people uh that I think
you you will recognize Rebecca Bennett
there on the bottom
um
some vignettes from that period of time
Applause uh Lance uh you know Davidson's
work was that was preceded by work by
Neil Rowe Miller and Julia Carroll all
the thesis problems on soil born wheat
viruses I don't have time to talk about
the other silicone virus but uh wheat
spindle Streak by Mo virus through
survey work and whatnot is the most
prevalent uh virus on small brains or on
wheat I should say in New York
um Neil did some really interesting work
where he went in and uh fumigated whole
plots that had a history of uh the
disease soil-borne disease and he saved
soil reinoculated by hand over
individual rows uh and we also had a
field that had a natural gradient of
disease and we paired up small plots of
resistant variety over that gradient and
we were able to make some estimates that
uh about 30 percent reduction in yield
for a disease that almost no farmer
recognized or know they had when the it
occurs in the early spring after the
crop when it's still cool out and once
it gets to you know 75 degrees outside
you don't see it anymore but even what
it was doing to the early development of
the plant we can get that kind of yield
impact so that was very interesting uh
Lance one of the things that I wish I
had time or someday maybe I will uh the
the Dogma is that this virus is
transmitted by uh a polymix agraminus a
soil-borne protozoan we have no proof
for that and nobody else has any proof
for I I think even until now Lance but
you found evidence that it was
replicating in another protozoan called
kalpota but we never quite got to prove
that it actually transmitted to wheat
and uh for about a year Michelle heck
also worked in our lab working on this
so that's one piece of unfinished
business I wish we could do someday
okay
and moving into the double knots
some other new characters on the scene
here
and uh it's a wonderful
people and particularly I want to
outline here the work of Dennis Shaw who
really really described the seed-born
nature of stagnospera no dorm watch on
wheat which is our most prevalent foliar
disease on wheat in New York state
and uh again I can't go through
everything there but we found it was
present in most of our seed both he and
then Rebecca Bennett after him uh did
some really nice work to show how the
same genetic diversity uh that people
have characterized in fields of foliage
is also all that diversity is right
there in a bag of seed when you plant it
in the ground and uh pair that up with
the fact that we did sport trapping
examining debris for years and could
never find an ask a sport
um our pseudotheism there so the Dogma
was it's Airborne it's coming from
wherever and ask of spores
it may at some point but in our
circumstances we could never validate
that and uh through some pretty elegant
work with uh with uh
genotyped isolates released and
recapture in the field we were able to
at least show that uh it's potentially a
lot of the initial inoculum in this
disease could be coming from seed
all right uh
one of my well uh Emerson Del Ponte uh
spent a year with me from Brazil and
here's another Dogma thing the Dogma is
that fusarium head blight is a single
cycle Disease an infection only occurs
exactly at flowering and it curse
through the anthers okay
it's not that simple it's
um I won't say much about these graphs
up here but we took a very susceptible
variety and we did inoculations through
every stage of of from flowering uh
through the maturity of the seed and we
look particularly at the at the buildup
of the mycotoxin in that seed and what
we in fact found was that you can get
infection all the way up to the dose
stages of development
what what is key is if you're going to
have a major impact on yield
those uh inoculations at flowering
through kind of the early grain
development kernel blister that's when
you get the big blast of toxin and you
get Major Impact on yield but a lot of
us have observed we have a year out in
the field we see no visual disease and
the farmer gets the it pulls the grain
to the elevator we won't buy it it's
full of toxin what's going on
because inoculation at later stages
natural inoculation can still result
very easily in more than two parts per
million in that seed
so we kind of expanded that window of
understanding a bit
um Brown root rot of alfalfa was a a
problem that uh we didn't understand
much about at all it's a it's a uh it's
actually a snow mold fungus it's the
most curious thing you can see those uh
amazing uh picnydia there with like the
the little antennae on them there it is
something to look at but it's uh
um this was the PHD thesis work of
Michael bunch and I don't know of a
student that's done more work for their
PHD thesis than Michael did I mean he
was just amazing but uh he surveyed
literally all over North America
he went to a lot of these places looking
in the soil
uh to make a long story short we got
this tremendous isolate collection we we
we looked at virulence we looked at uh
physical cultural characteristics what
anything you could dream of and and he
also looked at nine different genes to
do a multi-gene sequencing on it and we
came up with uh seven distinct plates
that we could have very easily called
new species but since we didn't know
that the biology was fundamentally any
different with any of these we we took
the conservative approach and we call
them varieties
so one of the things he did uh near the
end of his time here is he developed a a
two-step PCR protocol with indel primers
and whatnot that uh with those two steps
we could get uh first of all on the
first step we can identify fomus
chlorotioides at a species level then
with the uh with these combination of
these two steps we could get it down to
one of those seven
um
varieties
and uh the the small group excuse me the
forage breeding program here is
continuing some work that we started
with them trying to select varieties
populations in Northern York that are
both uh yeah I can see I'm going over
here but uh
um to try to get some resistant
varieties so I'll tell you what I'm
going to fly through a couple things
you're interested in these subjects come
join me for a cup of coffee sometime and
we'll talk about it but we've we've
worked on some really interesting work
on on new disease witch grass head smut
um
we found the first
mini era gramini around isolate in the
Americas that has high resistance to uh
to one of the triazole fungicides to
epiconazole
oh let's see
um this would be mostly about Julia
Crane's work on biological control of
fusarium
we've done some really fun work with
colleagues at Michigan State University
of Texas on uh switchgrass Leaf rust
and uh uh what's occupied a lot of our
time recently is working on malting
barley particularly the uh the thesis
work of Andrea Lugo Torres and Alyssa
blushes
so anybody really interested in that
topic you can join us at The Culinary
Institute of America in December and
we're going to have a summit a state
Summit on that and with a lot of uh
tasting uh
beers and Spirits made from New York
grain so if you need an enticement there
um I'm gonna I'm gonna end it right
there and uh I hope we had time for a
question or two
okay so anybody in the room Rebecca
cared for that one whole tour of course
everyone it's such a wonderful asset to
anybody else in the face pathology right
now is yes
comment on how you see the public health
implications of those different
technicians that you described like some
of them are you know as you mentioned
you know
new wish or not even tested foreign
is that important and sometimes bumping
a sample over the legal limit or just
plain important because 30 percent of
Don is not as okay so Rebecca basically
has a two-prong question the first of is
about safety with these mycotoxins and
these Commodities
um I do have some concerns uh
particularly
um you know we haven't seen ridiculously
high levels of the acetylated dawns but
on occasion we do
um and we're uh so in the commercial
trade in an industry in grades nobody is
routinely when you bring a tractor load
into a mill nobody's looking for
anything but not they're mostly Elisa
tests for Don okay and that's kind of
everything's focused on that I think
they I think in the future they may need
to look at total what we call beta
trichotherkins
um but our microbiological work is also
revealing that we have other fusarium
fungi that can produce some of these uh
Alpha trichotherkins like HT Toxin and
T2 toxins so nobody essentially nobody's
looking for those things today okay
other than researchers
um so I think that's something to be
addressed I mean I'm not yelling fire
here because I don't think we're finding
a lot but the potential is there
um
yeah and your second question was about
uh
the inoculum coming from different
places from the atmosphere from debris
what not and and and yeah sometimes
people hear me talk about this and they
think well he's saying it's not
important don't worry about it no if you
can if you have some health thing and
you could decrease your problem by 30
you're going to do it right so it's one
of the tools the the real message is you
need every tool in the tool chest unique
cultural practices yes you do but don't
count on it solving everything you knew
you need fungicide I've worked for quite
a while with the organic grain community
and I'm sorry to say I find nothing in
the uh organic Omri uh
sort of uh quiver there that's going to
uh really solve that right now but we
have a critical need there too and then
breeding
yeah other question
Alan
if you look at a crystal ball at the
projected climate change and other field
crop growing areas in the U.S across the
world I mean what what changes do you
see coming to New York State uh because
we seem to be in a sense a bit of a
sweet spot I think
yeah uh you know I think some well for
instance even fusarium's been uh
postulated that it's increasing because
of our our warming Trend but we're going
to see changes Alan I just don't know
precisely what they'll be it just as
some things will be more prevalent some
others may drop off that list I think
it's just going to be different
um but certainly the uh the trend of
having these major uh rainfall events
that that's a concern
um and and like we we saw almost no
foliar diseases the early part of the
Season well once it started raining in
August that all changed now almost any
cornfield I go in is is just up to the
gills with Northern corn Leaf blight
Northern corn leaf spot right now so
yeah it's just hard to say what those
changes are going to be yeah
and I saw there's a extension meeting
advertised in November I got a kick out
of it I kind of knew they're doing that
about growing rice in New York and
people are growing
small plots of of rice in the Hudson
Valley and in New England so who thought
we'd be talking about that right
Jillian
um we know
various forms are of dawn are bad for us
yeah right
how many of them are clearly plants very
Limitless determinants
I think the only strong evidence is for
Don itself at this point but I I don't
know I haven't kept up with some of the
people in Peoria and other places are
doing there but I've only seen evidence
that Don but you know they're they're
closely related molecules so it's it's
hard to believe that they wouldn't have
some impact as well
um yeah at one point I'd like to make
for people that are you know get scared
by oh all this done and everything uh
it's basically the farmers that are
taking the losses on this because the
it's not by and large getting through
indoor food products but that means that
the farmers can take a tremendous hit in
some years and the public not even be
aware of it so be nice to your Farmers
I just have a question sure of the 30
percent of yeah
and so
there's 70 it seems like there might be
two hypotheses like something similar to
the paksinian pathway breaks that up
yeah uh spores you know especially since
you're finding yeah scores and yeah low
atmosphere or whatever you call it yeah
um or the grasses that are you know like
so the only thing the only thing I could
say with absolute confidence is that
viable spores can come into a a field
from
kilometer distance and I say that
because we found viable spores in these
pontoon planes we flew over lakes and
stuff that were more than a mile across
and and so I could say that
is it 10 miles is it a hundred miles I
can't say we haven't figured out how to
attach those little radio transmitters
on the spores and follow them along like
they they do at the Ornithology lab
there but uh it does become speculation
uh there but the other thing is
interesting yes spores get exchanged
around regions but there is regional
structure to these populations
and you know what drives that there's
probably always some admixture there but
you know what what drives
Regional selection of different scales
we don't know yeah
further PhD problems in the interest of
time thank you everybody let's give Gary
a round of applause
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu